The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
mit.opencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
AMY BANZAERT: All right,
so those are all really
great presentations.
Thanks, you guys.
I'm excited about all the
projects you learned about
and things you accomplished.
So now, as I mentioned
at the beginning, what
we're going to do is very
quickly go through the design
process, and then talk about the
entire remainder of the class.
And part of that will be
you guys down-selecting
from the projects you've
just discussed to the top few
that you think are
good candidates.
And then tonight,
everyone in the class
will let me know
in a survey what
you want to actually work on.
And then, you'll be assigned
into your final project groups
on Friday.
So last year, some teams wanted
to work with the same community
partner, or all wanted
to work together,
and other teams wanted to
do something different.
So there's opportunity
for change or not change,
depending on what you want.
So basically, doing design
and the design process
is challenging for some
pretty standard reasons of you
have these really
severe trade-offs
between you want something
that's really light but really
strong, et cetera.
It can be a very
dynamic process.
There's a lot of things
happening at once.
There's a lot of
details to worry about.
There's always time
pressure and there's always
economic pressure.
And that's even more true
when you're doing design
for developing countries.
So you need to know your user
and understand the need, which
hopefully, you've just addressed
in your trip but of course,
in a week you're not going
to truly fully understand
everything.
There can be ethical
concerns that
come up that are
more severe than they
are at a typical
corporate design issue.
And there are some pretty
extreme design constraints
in terms of the costs, and the
robustness, and is it usable.
Can you manufacture
and distribute it?
And then also transparency--
is it easy to fix?
Do people really
understand how it works
can be even more important.
But it's all super rewarding,
too, so it's worth doing.
And so there's a lot
of different ways
that people consider
the design process.
So this is one way
of looking at it.
So first, you gather
information, which you just
did, hypothetically, and
define the problem, which
you are doing or just did.
And then you create
design specifications,
which you're doing this week,
generating ideas, evaluating
your concepts, doing some
analysis and experimentation
to really learn
what you're doing,
doing detail design to
work out all the details,
fabricating, testing,
and evaluation.
So that's one way
to think about it.
Another way is to think
about it from more
of a staged standpoint.
So you start with your
planning, and then you
get mission approval.
So thinking about it that way,
Friday is mission approval.
And then you do your
concept development,
and you have a concept
review, system-level design
with another review, detail
design and another review,
testing and refinement.
And then you're
approved for production
and can hypothetically
do production.
Oh, there are some crazy
controls here that I did not
put in, but clearly came up.
So I tried to just map how
these two approaches work
and how they connect.
And of course, there's
actually other ways
of describing the
design process.
And these all inter-link.
And I'm not going into
these in a lot of detail.
But we're going to just go
through this in the class
if you haven't seen it already.
But another one to look at is
your functional requirements.
So what does the
design have to do?
And then how is the design
going to meet the requirement?
Analyzing any decisions and
figuring out what you're doing,
doing the research
to make sure you're
not building a better
mousetrap when there's
plenty of good ones out there.
The risk-- what's
going to happen
if things don't work out?
And then your countermeasures--
what if things don't work?
What do you do?
And this is from
Alex Slocum, and he
likes to use language
that I don't always use.
This is from David
Wallace, who's
another Design Professor
of Mechanical Engineering.
So all of these methods
I've talked about all
seem relatively
linear, which is a lie.
So one way that
David likes to show
is that you're
always considering
your economic, your
physics, and your analysis.
But you start out with a lot of
breadth and very little depth.
And then as you go from
idea to concept to detail,
you get much more depth
and much less breadth.
But you're always cycling
through all of the steps.
So similarly, this is
another way of looking at it.
So right now, we're going to be
doing Pugh charts to figure out
your projects.
And then once you
figure your projects,
you're going to do more
Pugh charts to figure out
what your implementation is.
And then when you
figure that out, you're
going to get all the
way down to figuring out
am I going to use
a screw or a bolt
with a nut to connect
these things, which screw
or nut and bolt?
And so each time,
you're winnowing down.
And so you're repeating
a lot of the same things.
You're going to have to
go back and do research.
It's not like get
to do research once
at the beginning of
the class and you never
have to investigate
anything again.
It's just the level of
depth versus breadth
that you're considering.
I talked about this a little
bit previously on the charcoal
project and how
the press evolved.
But I just wanted to emphasize
that our class is, hopefully,
getting to a really
good prototype.
And sometimes students have in
mind that's the end process.
And that's not the best
way to think about things.
If you think about,
say, an iPod,
it started out 10 years
ago with one iteration.
And that was a
production product
that had many prototypes
ahead of itself.
And now, if you think 10 years
later, not only does the iPod
itself look really
different, but there's also
all these other implementations
of the iPod that are out there,
and many, many devices
along the way to get there.
So that's just true.
And iPod is an obviously
complex example,
but something even as simple
as a Netflix envelope in seven
years has gone through a
ridiculous number of design
changes and improvements.
So it's just a reality
of the design process
that you're always getting
to the next, to a good stage,
hopefully, but you're
not ever getting to--
you can't think that your first
prototype, the orange juice bag
stealer is a great example.
You delivered it.
It made sense a
year ago for being
checked to 12 volt battery.
And now you can't find any,
and it has a different need,
and there's other
needs coming up.
So there's always going
to be optimizations.
OK, so I want to go
over a Pugh chart
today because that's what
you're going to be using.
If you haven't seen
it, Pugh was a guy
who came up with this method.
And so it's just a way of
comparing different ideas.
It seems, in some
ways that you do it,
it seems like it can be
kind of quantitative.
And it's absolutely not.
It's an entirely
qualitative method,
and using it quantitatively is
defeating the purpose of it.
So the way you use it
is you have a bunch
of criteria on your
left vertical axis,
and then a bunch of
options that you compare.
I always pick the bad marker.
A little better.
And so today, we're just going
to compare a nail to a ring
shank nail to a
staple and a screw.
So when you're
doing a Pugh chart,
you're usually
doing it in a group.
And so it's a good idea to
make sure that everyone knows
what each of these options are.
So it can be helpful to
draw like a really fast,
simple diagram just so
that everyone, you're sure,
has in mind what
the differences are.
So if you don't know,
a ring shank nail
is somewhere between
a screw and a nail,
and that it has little
rings on the edge
so that it helps prevent
the nail from popping
back out once you drive it in.
But you still drive it
in like a nail as opposed
to screwing it in like a screw.
And then a staple, obviously.
So it's nice to have
a drawing, as well.
And then you need
some criteria for how
you're going to compare
all of these options.
And so you just go
through what you think
are the most important ones.
There are more
complicated charts
that are versions of
Pugh charts, where
you can put different weighting
on your different criteria.
That gets really hard
to do, especially
as you have more criteria,
like how much more important
is holding than effort?
It gets a little complicated
to figure that out.
So sometimes, because
this is so qualitative,
just having these out there
and then keeping in mind
your mental weightings,
is sufficient.
And so then you want one of
your items to be your standard.
So this is really
important, that you just
pick one that you think
might be the most standard,
and just give it an
S for standard, or 0,
or whatever you want to use.
It's tempting not
to give a standard
because it's kind of annoying.
It might mean that some--
like if the nail is
the cheapest option,
then your standard--
everything else
is going to be more expensive.
Everything else is going
to be off the chart.
So it's not actually in the
middle, which is what you want.
However, you always need
to compare to something
because there's no neutral.
So you have to
define your neutral.
So this is the way they do that.
So while it's tempting
to not define a neutral,
it makes the Pugh chart a whole
lot more useful if you do.
And then you can just go
through and grade them,
so a ring shank
in terms of rate.
And some people like to go down.
Some people like to go across.
It's whatever you prefer.
So a ring shank is about the
same speed, a staple is faster.
A screw is probably slower.
So that's just how you do it.
For a cost, a ring shank is
going to be more expensive.
And that's another
confusing thing--
more expensive seems
like it should be a plus,
but it's actually a minus
because that's worse.
A staple will be
cheaper and a screw
is going to be more expensive.
For holding, a ring
shank is a little better,
staple's a little worse.
A screw is a whole lot better.
So you can do
minuses and pluses.
You can do 1s and 2s.
If you do 1s and 2s,
again, this is qualitative,
so no adding those
numbers at the end.
And for effort, a
shank is similar.
A staple is probably easier,
and a screw is harder.
So as I said, a lot
of people are then
tempted to put a line
at the bottom, and be,
like, this is a 0.
This is a 0.
This is [INAUDIBLE],,
which is not
the way to use a Pugh chart.
So don't ever do this.
And the reason is
that again, there's
different qualities,
different weightings for all
of these things.
So adding these up
isn't that meaningful,
and isn't a good way
to make a decision.
But it does very quickly
help you determine, just
looking what are the
pros and cons of each one
in a visual way that's pretty
fast to really think about
the pros and cons, and
make sure you're actually
considering the pros and cons
that are important to you.
And then finally, if we didn't
have the ring shank here,
and you saw the
nail and the screw,
the Pugh chart is
something that might
lead you to develop the ring
shank, where you're, like, OK,
the screw is slower,
and the cost is worse,
and effort is worse, but
holding is really good.
What could I do that would
combine my screw with my nail
to get me a better product?
And that might lead you to
develop the ring shank now.
So that's one nice way
to use the Pugh chart is
to combine projects or
concepts, and help you do
that in a way that works well.
Are there any questions
about the Pugh chart?
Because you're going to
use it in 10 minutes.
OK.
And this is just--
there it is.
Another tool that's common
that you might want to use
is when you're
developing a schedule,
people often use something
called a Gantt chart.
And can't read most
of what's on here.
But basically,
you have your list
of tasks, how long
they're going to take,
and then you spread them out.
And the thing that's important
or helpful about a Gantt chart
is listing the tasks
that rely on each other.
So if one of your tasks is, say,
you're doing that rice husking
and you need a mill, and
you hadn't bought that mill,
you'd have to order a mill,
and it would have to be here.
And you can't do any
testing with your mill
until it gets here.
And so that's on
the critical path
because you need
to do the testing.
And therefore, that means you
need to order it yesterday.
And it's a good thing you bought
it, so this is a helpful way
to think about your schedule.
It's not a requirement
in this class
that you use a Gantt
chart, so I'm not
going to talk about it anymore.
But you can Google it and
find lots of different tools.
But it's just one way of
building your schedule that
works pretty well.
So some of the best practices
for doing the design process
are one, to have people
assigned to different roles.
So some roles that
work really well
are someone who's in
charge of your timeline.
So are you hitting
those dates that you
outline on your schedule?
And regardless, what
can we do right now?
So if you're waiting
for that mill to arrive
or whatever you've
ordered to arrive,
it can be really
tempting to be like,
oh, there's nothing to do today.
It'll be here on Friday and I
won't do anything until then.
And that's really dangerous
because time is so tight.
And so figuring out what can we
do right now, even if it's not
on the critical path, just to
make sure we're moving forward,
and then having
someone else who's
making sure that
what you're doing
is actually related
to your goal.
Because it can be
easy to get really
involved in figuring out
the perfect adhesive,
and doing an adhesive analysis,
when your goal is just
to have a good enough
adhesive, and you
should use the first one
you found and go with it,
or whatever.
And then having someone who's
the key person on your team
who's in charge of communicating
with your community partner--
for this class I'm going to
ask that you try to communicate
with a partner once a week.
Some of you may have a
hard time doing that.
But you should at
least be trying
to communicate once
a week so that you're
getting regular feedback.
And then finally,
documentation--
making sure that you're
documenting what you do well,
which you'll really
thank yourselves
for at the end of the class
when you have to write
a final report as a team.
The more documentation
you do ahead of time,
the easier that'll.
Be and then general
recommendations
are failing fast, is one.
And so it's much
better to figure out
that your idea
doesn't work today
than it is the day
before your presentation.
And so the sooner you
can be developing stuff
so that you can figure
out those failures
and fixing them, the better.
And so along those lines,
prototyping early and often.
And then finally, identifying
any of your deal breakers
immediately.
So any physical
impossibilities or things that
are just not going to work--
figuring those out as
soon as possible so
that you don't get into failing
spectacularly, but only failing
in small areas that
you can recover from.
Oh, I don't know why these
slides are like this.
I'm sorry, guys.
I should have run
through it ahead of time.
I didn't think it
would be in there.
Anyway, so I picked
one of those design
processes to run us
through what we're doing.
And we're basically doing each
stage of the design process
in a week, which is
ridiculously fast.
But it's why the pressure
is on automatically,
from today, because this
is all the time we have.
Your final presentation is on
May 7, which is a Saturday.
It's in your syllabus.
So if you aren't
free on that day,
you should talk to me real soon.
But we're doing them as a group
with the other D-Lab classes.
And so that's six weeks
total is what we have.
And so everything we're
doing is basically,
we have a week for each
stage, which is very rapid.
And that really drives what
your project should be.
So as you probably noticed when
I showed last year's projects,
none of them were inventing a
brand-new washing machine, say.
It was making a very small,
incremental improvement
on something.
And that's what you
want to do because it's
much better to have
a really awesome
small, incremental
improvement that'll actually
help your organization and
be of benefit, than to make
very small progress on a really
big project that's not going
to help anyone because
you haven't completed it
by the end of the semester.
So I've created a
Part Two syllabus,
which I'll hand out as soon as
I pick them up from the copier.
But basically, it has
what we're doing each day,
and then the assignments due.
And then below
this, the schedule
is a bunch of details
about each assignment.
So hopefully, everything
will be super clear.
But things to know
is that there's
a lot of time this
unscheduled where I'm not
going to be lecturing at all.
Amit is not going to
be lecturing at all.
It's just time for
your team to work.
That doesn't mean you
should blow off class.
We're still checking attendance.
We still expect you to be here.
The work time is
pretty valuable.
Amit and I will be stopping
by each team every session
at least once to check
in on how you're doing.
Your mentors will be stopping
by almost every session
to check in and help you.
So it's a good
time to work where
you know your team
members are available,
where if it's out of class time,
it's harder to get everyone
together in a group.
And so along those
lines, if you're not
going to be working
in this classroom,
your team should
leave a note where
you are so that as Amit
and I are doing our rounds,
we can find you.
So again, we actually do
expect you to be here.
And then second is you're going
to be creating a wiki page.
There's a wiki link off
of the Stellar website.
And so each team should have
a wiki page where you can
document your design process.
So rather than having
physical design books, which
get really challenging
in terms of you
want them with at
all times, I need
to take them to
grade them, D-Lab
has started doing
wikis so that we
can do grading without
stealing your design notebooks
and stuff like that.
So that's what you should
document everything.
And it's also useful
for future classes.
They get to see everything
that you've worked on,
so that can be helpful.
And then there will be a
design review on April 22,
where you will have 10 minutes
to present your project.
And we'll have people
from outside the class
coming to give feedback.
And there, you'll want
to have a prototype.
And I'll talk more about
that as it gets closer.
And then the final
presentation's where you'll--
it's this combo
where you're both
doing a public
presentation that'll
be one minute along
with a poster session.
That's what you're
used to if you've
done previous D-Lab
classes in the spring.
And then also doing
a more formal design
review where you'll
leave the poster session
and have a formal design review
in a separate room, as well.
We used to do those
separately, and we're
trying to combine them
just for efficiency sake.
And then finally, you'll
have a final report,
which is written up well here.
And then I'll go through
more as we get closer.
So what are we doing now?
You guys need to finalize
what your actual projects are
going to be.
And so what I'd like you to do
is come up with your top end
projects, hopefully at least
three and no more than six,
I would say, would
be a good range.
And do a Pugh chart
with them so that you
can come up with the best--
figure out what projects
are worth working on.
And you should come up with one
or two are the ones that you
recommend going ahead with.
And then at 2:30, which--
wow, I don't
[INAUDIBLE] do micro
presentations, because
things went long.
So probably, we'll
just have you do the--
just by the end
of class, you need
to hand in to me what are
your top couple of projects
with a little description
that you can email me,
so that everyone can know
what they're working on.
But hopefully, you're not too
far afield from what you just
presented, so people
have a general idea
of what you're working on.
So before I let
you go, I just want
to do one last thing,
which is what Pugh
criteria we should be using.
Because you can have some
variation [INAUDIBLE]
you think we should use.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so
your budget is about $500.
So you definitely don't want
to be inventing anything that's
going to require $50,000.
What else?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] So
what if we get funding?
What if our project
is an awesome idea?
Can I look for funding
somewhere else and--
AMY BANZAERT: Yes, but
you have six weeks.
So you're unlikely to get
funding in these six weeks
there.
Like if it's $700, let's talk
about what you actually need.
But most teams had budget
left over last year
when they had $500.
So I don't think this is
a super high constraint.
It just gives you an
order of magnitude.
So what else?
STUDENT: Materials availability.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so I think
a bigger general one is--
do you mean like locally?
STUDENT: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
AMY BANZAERT: So then
that would probably
be something more specific
for different examples
or different projects,
like if you have
12 ideas for your rice husker.
But I think for here, one
that's along those lines
is just does it
help your community?
And embedded in that is
if they can't build it,
it's not going to help them.
But we're looking at very
broad strokes at this level.
Any others?
STUDENT: It's going to
be finished in six weeks.
AMY BANZAERT: Yeah, so
"si se puede," right?
We want to be able to say that.
So that's pretty important,
to be able to say yes, we can.
My son is really
into Bob the Builder,
and that's all I hear
is, can we build it?
Yes, we can.
And then one other
that's important to me
is that it's relevant to
the Energy class, which
I think they all are.
But a water project might
be really compelling.
It's not relevant to energy.
So you want to make sure
that it does actually
fit within the
boundaries of the class,
but they're pretty
broadly defined.
So these are the
four that I really
want to make sure you
include, that you might
want to add others, as well.
But every team
should include these.
Are there any questions?
So I'm going to grab
the revised syllabi
and the big paper that you can
use to make Pugh charts on.
And that's what you
should be doing.
And by the end of the class,
you need to have top projects.
Great.